well the fantasy of Russian collegian
continues to dominate American political
if it doesn't matter that almost nobody
actually believes any of it and never
has proving not as exist in collision
was never the point of the exercise the
point obviously was blame-shifting
Hillary didn't lose the election the
political establishment wasn't
completely out of touch with voters the
media weren't embarrassingly wrong about
everything
nope none of that happened Putin did it
it's his fault
it all began as a psychological exercise
a way for a stunned ruling class to feel
better about itself in the face of
humiliating loss but from there the
Russia story became a handy way to
hamstring a young and honestly
disorganized administration as Donald
Trump spent a single day in office not
responding to this ludicrous conspiracy
theory probably not and that was by
design you know all this by now it's
contemptible and dishonest but the
looming question is is all of us
becoming dangerous to the rest of us
Russia isn't just a CNN topic is such a
script on MSNBC it's an actual country
with borders and millions of people and
one of the largest nuclear arsenals in
the world so you would think we would
tread carefully when it really came down
to it because there's no advantage in
exacerbating our rivalry with Russia
pointlessly there's an obvious downside
to it war in which millions could die
and yet our leaders seem intent on
driving us toward actual confrontation
with the actual country of Russia
Congress bipartisan coalition in
Congress is United for some reason
behind passing more and deeper sanctions
against Russia why because it's immoral
not to shut up they explained in Syria
meanwhile which is a client state of
Russia US airstrikes reportedly have
killed hundreds of Russians the media
are crying for more more blood okay but
is this advancing any serious American
interest not that we can see but as long
as we're picking fights with Russia
everyone in Washington can retroactively
lis justify the mindless Muller
investigation this is lunacy but it
could very soon get very scary